The release of the Auschwitz report
is headline news throughout the
country.
These news reports
explaining to the American people
what Auschwitz was and what happened
there are followed up
by op-eds, by columns
about Auschwitz and what America
has to do in the wake of
all of this information.
Fully two thirds of European Jews
were killed by the Nazis during
World War Two.
In a systematic, relentless process
that continues to exceed our ability
to comprehend its origins and
consequences.
The final solution, which was the
Nazi plan to exterminate all
European Jews, wasn't implemented
until 1942.
But Hitler's government had begun
openly dehumanizing, harassing,
and attacking Jews nine years
earlier.
Even when the Nazi death machine
kicked into high gear.
America mostly kept its doors
closed to Jews as filmmakers
Ken Burns, Lynn Novick and Sarah
Botstein recount in the U.S.
in the Holocaust, a three part
documentary series on PBS.
The anxieties about urbanization,
about unlettered, untutored,
relatively uneducated peoples
coming in, in large numbers, and
the sense that disease was
a problem.
All of these worries were
amalgamated into
a belief that immigrants caused
these problems and thus immigration
should be held down.
Some lobbied to open the country to
refugees in the run up to war.
But anti-immigration legislation,
the economic devastation of the
depression, incredulity
toward a press that had trafficked
in false atrocity accounts during
World War One, and deep seated
anti-Semitism, especially
in Franklin Roosevelt's State
Department, combined to thwart
those efforts.
Reason talked with Burns and Novick
about why a nation of immigrants
remains so deeply ambivalent
about newcomers and the lessons
that 21st century America
should draw from our country's
response in the lead up to the
Holocaust.
Lynn Novick.
Ken Burns, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Thank you for having us.
So the series
begins in in
the early thirties, and it's
actually you're talking about Otto
Frank, who is known to
everybody as the father of Anne
Frank and kind of the person who
brought the diary to notice.
But it's in Frankfurt
and Otto Frank is
what you're talking about is his
plans, his thwarted plans
to bring his family to America.
Why is it so important that, you
know, you start the series with
this question of Otto
Frank not being able to bring
his family to the United States
at the very beginning of the Nazi
era?
You know, we started out to make a
series about the United States
and the Holocaust and what was our
relationship to what was happening
in Europe and what did we as
Americans know and what should we do
about it just collectively?
And while we were working on the
film, which has been many years in
the making, some documents came
to light that showed
Otto Frank, Anne Frank's father,
writing to friends in the United
States asking for help to get here.
And that was just extraordinary
for us to recognize that the story
of Anne Frank, we thought, I speak
for myself and I think most of us
felt this was a story about the
Holocaust that happened over there,
had nothing to do with America.
And here's one of the most
recognizable stories of
the Holocaust.
Has a lot to do with America.
So we decided to frame
our film around that idea
by telling the story of Otto Frank
and his efforts to get to America to
help our audience sort of see
themselves in this story.
And in 1933, it's
the Depression.
It's about a decade after
the Johnson-Reed Act, which
was the culmination of 40
years of legislative activism
or activism to shut down
immigration, particularly from
central and southern Europe.
Why? Why is immigration, you
know, what what's going
on with the way immigration was
restricted a decade before when,
you know, during the Roaring
Twenties?
How does that factor into what's
going on next?
So there are two important things
about immigration. One is symbolic,
like what kind of country are we?
You know, are we the Emma Lazarus?
Give us your tired, your poor nation
of immigrants?
Or are we an almost equal
reaction to that?
No, let us stop this.
So between 1870 and 1920,
millions and millions of people come
from areas that are threatening
to the Protestant majority, and they
want to figure out a way to go back
to a an
earlier time, always impossible.
And when it was a dominant,
there was a fear was that these
newcomers who from Central and
southern Europe, Catholic and
Eastern Europe, Catholic and Jews,
would would they be replacing
us?
And so the Johnson-Reed Act is an
attempt to essentially set quotas
from the countries, that's minuscule
quotas, from the countries that are
less desirable and bigger quotas
of people from the Northern
European.
Who iron- not, ironically,
but are not emigrating in the
numbers where, you know.
So Germany gets big quotas,
but not that many people are coming.
And then places like Italy get
very low quotas.
And a lot of people want to move
here.